most physics books will tell you that
the acceleration due to gravity near the
surface of the earth is 9.81 m/s^2 and
this is an approximation and what I want
to do in this video is figure out if
this is the value we get when we
actually use Newton's law of universal
gravitation and that tells us that the
force of gravity between two objects and
let's just talk about the magnitude of
the force of gravity between two objects
is equal to the gravitational constant
the universal gravitational constant
times the mass of one of the bodies m1
times the mass of the second body
divided by the distance between the
center of masses of the body squared so
the distance between the center of the
masses of the body squared so let's use
this the universal law of gravitation to
figure out what the acceleration due to
gravity should be at the surface of the
earth and I have G right over here I
have the mass of the earth which I've
looked up over here and we also have the
radius of the earth and for the sake of
this we're going to assume that the
distance between the body if we're at
the center of if we're at the surface of
the earth the distance between that and
the center of the earth is just going to
be is just going to be the radius of the
earth and so this will give us the
magnitude of the force if we want to
figure out the magnitude of the
acceleration which this really is I
actually didn't write this as a vector
so this is just the magnitude of the
acceleration if you wanted the
acceleration which is a vector you would
have to say downwards or towards the
center of towards the center of the
earth in this case but if you want the
acceleration we just have to remember we
just have to remember that force force
is equal to mass times acceleration and
if you wanted to solve for acceleration
you just divide both sides times mass so
force divided by mass is equal to is
equal to acceleration or if you want the
magnitude if you take the magnitude of
your force and you divide by mass you're
going to get the magnitude of your
acceleration this is a scalar quantity
this is
scalar quantity right over here so if
you want the acceleration due to gravity
you divide let's say let's let's write
this in terms of the force of gravity on
earth so the magnitude of the force of
gravity on earth this one right over
here so this will be in the case of
earth are destroyed earth really really
small so one of these masses is going to
be earth it's going to be this mass
right over here and so if you wanted the
acceleration of at this acceleration due
to gravity at the surface of the earth
you would just have to divide you just
have to divide by the mass that is being
accelerated due to that force and in
this case it is the other mass it is the
mass that's sitting on the surface so
let's divide both sides by that mass
let's divide both sides by that mass and
this will give us the magnitude of the
magnitude of the acceleration on that
mass due to gravity so this is equal to
the magnitude of acceleration the
magnitude of the acceleration due to
gravity and the whole reason why this is
actually a simplifying thing is that
these two this m2 right over here and
this m2 cancels out and so the magnitude
of our acceleration the magnitude of our
acceleration due to gravity using
Newton's universal law of gravitation is
just going to be this expression right
over here it's going to be it's going to
be the gravitational constant times the
mass of the earth divided by the
distance between the object the object's
center of mass and the center of the
mass of the earth and we're going to sue
that the object is right at the surface
then its center of mass is right at the
surface so this is actually going to be
the radius of the earth squared so
divided by radius squared sometimes this
is also viewed as the gravitational
field at the center at the surface of
the earth if because if you multiply it
by a mass it tells you how much force is
pulling on that mass but with that out
of the way let's actually use a
calculator to calculate what this value
is and then what I want to do is figure
out well one I want to compare it to the
value that the textbooks give us and see
maybe why it may or may not be different
and then think about how it changes as
we get further and further away from the
surface of the earth and per tick
if we get to an altitude that the Space
Shuttle or the International Space
Station might be at and this is an
altitude of 400 kilometers is where it
tends to hang out give or take a little
bit depending on what it is up to so
first let's just figure out what this
value is when we use the universal law
of gravitation so let's get my
calculator out let's get the calculator
out so we know what G is it is six point
six seven three eight times 10 to the
negative 11 this EE button means
literally times 10 to the negative 11 so
this is six point six seven three eight
times 10 to the negative 11 and then I
want to multiply that times the mass of
Earth times the mass of Earth which is
right over here it is five point nine
seven two two times ten to the 24th so
times 10 to the 24th power and we want
to divide that by the radius of Earth
squared so divided by the radius of
Earth is so this is in kilometers and I
just want to make sure that everything
is in the same meet in the same units so
6,371 kilometers actually let me scroll
over well you can't see the kilometers
right over this is in kilometers is the
same thing as six million three hundred
seventy one thousand meters if you just
multiply this by a thousand or you could
even write this as six point three seven
seven one six point three seven one
times 10 to the sixth times 10 to the
sixth meters and we're going to square
this that's the radius of the earth the
distance between the center of mass of
Earth and the center of mass of this
object which is sitting at the surface
of the earth and so let's get our
drumroll and we get nine point eight and
if we round we actually get something a
little bit higher than what the
textbooks give us we get nine point
eight two let's just round so we get
nine point eight two nine point eight
two meters per second squared and so you
might say well what's going on here why
do we have this discrepancy between what
the universal law of gravitation gives
us and with the average measured
acceleration due to
due to the force of gravity at the
surface of the earth and the discrepancy
here the discrepancy between these two
numbers is really because earth is not a
uniform sphere of uniform density earth
is and that's what we had to assume
right over here when we use the
universal law of gravitation it's
actually a little bit flatter then then
you would then you would then a perfect
sphere and it definitely does not have
uniform density the different layers or
earth have different densities you have
all sorts of different interactions and
then you also if you measure effective
gravity there's also a little bit of a
buoyancy effect from from the air very
very very very negligible I don't know
if it would have been enough to to
change this but there's other minor
minor effects irregularities earth is
not a perfect sphere it is not of
uniform density and that's what accounts
for the bulk of this now that out of the
way what I'm curious about is what is
the acceleration due to gravity if we go
up 400 kilometers so now the main
difference here G will stay the same the
mass of Earth will stay the same but the
radius is now going to be different
because now we're placing the center of
mass of our object whether it's a Space
Station or someone sitting in the space
station they're going to be 400
kilometers higher and I'm going to
exaggerate what 400 kilometers looks
like this is not drawn to scale but now
the radius is going to be the radius of
the earth plus 400 kilometers so now for
this for the case of the space station R
is going to be not 6,371 kilometers it's
going to be 6,000 we're going to add 400
to this 6771 kilometers which is the
same thing as 6 million seven hundred
seventy one thousand meters which is the
same thing as six point seven seven one
times 10 to the sixth meters this is one
two three four five six ten to the sixth
meters so let's go back to our
calculator and we should just be able so
second entry that's the last entry we
had instead of six point three seven one
times 10 to the sixth let's add 400
kilometers to that so then we get six
point sorry six point seven so we're
adding 400 kilometers so it was three
seven one now it's seven seven one times
ten
the sixth and what do we get we get
eight point six nine meters per second
squared so now the acceleration here
acceleration here is a eight point six
nine meters per second squared and you
can verify that the unit's work out
because over here gravity is in meters
cubed per kilogram second squared you
multiply that times the mass of Earth
which is in kilograms the kilograms
cancel out with these kilograms and then
you're dividing by meters squared so you
divide this by meters squared you get
you're left with meters per second
squared so the units work out as well so
there's an important thing to realize
and this is a misconception we do a
whole video on it earlier when we talk
about the universal law of gravitation
is that there is gravity when you are in
orbit up here the only reason why it
feels like there's not gravity or it
looks like there's not gravity is that
this space station is moving so fast
that it's essentially in free fall but
it's moving so fast that it keeps
missing the earth it keeps missing the
earth and in the next video we'll figure
out how fast does it have to travel in
order for it to stay in orbit in order
for it to not plummet to earth due to
this due to the force of gravity due to
the acceleration that is occurring this
centripetal this Center seeking
acceleration